younes belle fait la économiste et
spécialiste du monde arabe
bonsoir younes el fellah merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors jusqu'ici
ça l'egypte et la jordanie avait reconnu
l'existence d'israël tous les autres
pays sont toujours en état de guerre
avec l'état juif
comment est-ce que vous interprétez
cette normalisation aujourd'hui des
émirats et de bahreïn spécifiquement
aujourd'hui bonsoir moi je crois que
c'est une action qui était prévu après
la normalisation des relations avec avec
les immigrants sont face à un projet
américain de créer des bons liens entre
les pays arabes et israël est
effectivement c'est un changement
historique c'est un changement
historique parce qu'on est face à une
nouvelle politique des axes dans la
région du moyen orient et dans les pays
du golfe il faut rappeler que dans après
1948 et la création de l'état de l'état
d'israël les deux premiers pays dans la
région qui ont reconnu l'état d'israël
c'était la turquie et l'iran est
actuellement avec cette normalisation
des relations avec les pays du avec les
pays du golfe en est face à un laps
arabo-israélien effectivement contre
l'iran en chine et la turquie des frères
des frères musulmans donc c'est une
volonté américaine de concrétiser un
projet de paix d'alliance entre israël
et les pays arabes dont je peux pas dire
qu'il ya délit à un état de guerre du
fait qu il sait pas ce que sera le barça
sera pas le dernier pays qui va
normaliser les relations avec israël
mais on sera vraiment face à un effet
domino dans toute la région du moyen
orient
vous pensez vraiment qu'il y aura cet
effet domino vous parler de nouvelle
bête politique des axes qu'est ce que
les monarchies du golfe ont à gagner à
signer ces accords concrètement d'abord
son besoin d israël pour créer une
alliance contre l'errance rappeler bien
sûr qu'il ya une menace iranienne pour
certains pays des gauchos pas les
émirats ou le bahreïn même le bain c'est
un cas qui y étaient très
exceptionnellement sata dans cette
région le pouvoir avant les unissent
dans un pays à majorité chiite est là
subi beaucoup de mal à ce de cette
extension iranien dans dans la région ça
c'est là qu'on va dire la politique et
sécuritaire qui est très important après
il ya un axe aussi qui est très
important pour la région en transition
économique
donc c'est l'axé économique c'est le
fait de créer des opportunités avec
israël en terme d' échanges commerciales
en termes de le fait de profiter de la
technologie israélien de créer des
opportunités d'investissement développer
le tourisme dans cette région d'ailleurs
on a vu même après la normalisation des
relations avec avec les émirats on a
commencé directement de parler de
certains projets de certains
investissements des compagnies aériennes
sont bien profiter de cette situation
pour créer de nouveaux espaces aériens
dans dans la région donc effectivement
on est face à un changement et je crois
qu'il y en a d'autres pays zara pas
seulement les pays du golfe qui se
prépare pour ce jour du pour ce genre de
décision bahreïn a affirmé que cela
améliorera les la stabilité c'est ce que
vous nous dites instabilité et donc
économies dans la région sécurité
également ce sera le cas selon vous
je crois que pour pour les pays d'avoir
maintenant ils voient qu'il ya deux
menaces dans cette région il ya une
menace iranienne qui était très déclaré
à travers la politique d aider des
proxys donc j'ai pas mal de fils mandla
où il est bon les outils yémen etc et a
aussi la menace turque immobilisés par
la mouvance ddd des frères musulmans est
il du fait que les pays de gauche n'ont
pas de frontière avec israël ne subit
pas on va dire de menaces directes par
israël au contraire ils partagent cette
hostilité verts ils iront ils voient
qu'il ya des opportunités d'affaires
avec israël donc le projet de paix avec
israël il est plus crédible pour les les
pays les pays du golfe maintenant la
question qu'il faut poser par rapport à
la situation des palestiniens
c'est à dire que là on entend qu'il y
ait des déclarations de l'autorité
palestinienne ou même du hamas contre ce
genre sont contre ce genre d'actions
sachant bien que le différend entre les
autorités palestiniennes du fatah est
également le hamas qui a contribué à à
ce jour d'une décision c'est à dire à
une absence d'un projet palestinien à un
rochus d'un projet de paix avec les
israéliens et donc pour cela on voit
puis ya des pays arabes
rennes en fin de compte la décision ou
l'initiative de faire des relations
directes et de normaliser leurs
relations avec israël
à l'instar de ce qui s'était passé avant
avec l'egypte et la jordanie les
palestiniens le hamas à gaza et
l'autorité palestinienne en cisjordanie
disent que c'est un coup de poignard
dans le dos des palestiniens
bahreïn qui pourtant étaient pour et
toujours peut-être pour la création d'un
état palestinien les deux sont
compatibles
je crois qu'il y avait une initiative
arabe qu'il était lancée par l'arabie
saoudite en 2002 keith tu peux le fait
de créer deux états israël et palestine
elle est le fait que les arabes aux
couleurs en fin de compte la légitimité
d'israël dans dans la région et ouvre
une nouvelle page historique avec avec
le pays je crois que il ya suspens
diction jusqu'à maintenant pour les pour
les pourris les états du golfe mais le
problème actuellement en palestine c'est
la question de la légitimité du pouvoir
c'est à dire on sait pas avec qui on va
parler on sait pas avec qui on peut
développer des négociations des
négociations politiques donc ce
différend et ce conflit palestino
palestiniens à a contribué en quelque
sorte à le fait que les pays zara près
dé cette décision effectivement de créer
de nouveaux liens avec avec les
israéliens sachant bien que ce genre de
décision effectivement confirme la
présence et la puissance des états unis
dans cette région merci beaucoup younès
belle félin d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france